Egyptians are key is foreign ministers
are meeting in Ankara and another step
towards thawing strained relations ties
between the two countries soured in
2013. that's when
led a military coup against the elected
president Muhammad Morsi a Turkish Ally
from 2017 turkey is supported Qatar
during a four-year blockade by Egypt
Bahrain Saudi Arabia and the UAE the
rift deepened in 2019 when turkey and
Egypt backed opposing sides during the
war in Libya but a handshake between
both presidents during last year's World
Cup in Qatar signaled the resumption of
talks in March Egypt's foreign minister
visited turkey following devastating
earthquakes in its Southern and Central
regions we'll bring in cinema Kosovo Glu
from Ankara so what's being discussed in
this meeting and how significant is it
well the the the the bilateral meeting
today between two ministers was
important because it is having a way for
a summit between the presidents of two
countries but of course there were so
many important uh topics on the table
during at first Libya was one of the
most important topics Syria Jerusalem
besides the bilateral cooperation and
economic cooperation uh to top diplomats
discussed how they could cooperate on
the regional Regional peace and
stability Apparently after a 10 11 year
old stole off diplomatic relations two
countries have understood that they have
weight in solving the original issues in
Libya they have been defending the
opposite sides of the conflict but as
Turkish foreign minister said during the
joint press conference which ended a
couple of minutes ago he said we
understood that our final goals are the
same two countries are asking for for a
territorial Integrity political unity
and sovereignty for Libya for the
benefit of Libya and both Egypt and
tricky on the other side they discuss
Syria the stability and Security in
Syria and turkey's recent engagement
with the Syrian government in Damascus
besides that energy was on the table as
a Egypt is one of the leading energy
players in the Eastern Mediterranean and
trukia is in conflict with Greece and
Cyprus in the Eastern Mediterranean
energy drill issues Egypt is also trying
to mediate and also turkey asking for
asking Egypt to transfer its LNG to 2km
as tsuki is aiming to be an energy Hub
and once they export Egyptian gas to the
third parties okay and synonym could
this pave the way for a meeting between
President erdogan and president sisi
this is what tutor diplomats mentioned
during also Turkish foreign minister
just two days ago when he announced that
his Egyptian counterpart would visit
Ankara he mentioned that two presidents
of uh to to
friendly countries may come together
they the top diplomats didn't give any
timing for the summit but they said they
are preparing on a timeline on a draft
plan that will bring to presidents
together but they avoided to to say any
specific date for this there there were
news on the turkey side that this
meeting could happen after the election
that is going to take place on May 14.
however this is going to be the most
challenging election for the Turkish
president as the polls suggests that his
Rivals the nation Alliance the six
opposition parties Allied against uh AG
party and its nationalist Ally are also
carrying a great chance of winning the
elections but so far it is expected to
be to happen after the election okay
thank you so much reporting from Ankara